- Make Tyra proud and just prune
like one of the Olsen twins.
(music mix)
- I feel like posing on red carpets
is a lot of hands on the hip,
at least that's what I would do.
- Everyone seems to look
perfect on The Red Carpet.
- I don't know how people
are able to look so good
when they're wearing these crazy outfits,
which they are like
definitely sweating in,
unless celebrities don't sweat.
- I'm doing the seated pic,
which I'm a little uncomfortable
about because I'm wearing
like a pretty tight skirt
and I'm like sitting
on this weird bench, so
I have no idea, maybe like
arch my back or sit up straighter.
(camera snapping)
- I had the head-shot
today so from the chest up,
and just focusing in on the money-maker.
I just don't know how you look so good
under so much pressure.
- I am doing the full-body
shot, which is always
the one that can go wrong
because you never know
where to put your hands, your face,
you just have so many things
to worry about at one time.
- I was assigned the candid photo.
It's actually harder than
it looks, kind of walk
back-and-forth while candidly
looking at the camera.
- It's like you're fitting
so many different hot people
in one photo, I feel--
- [Guy] It's overwhelming.
- Way too much hotness
in one photo.
- I mean with Ellen's selfie,
I needed to put my phone down
for five minutes, and
just kind of recompose
and like have a drink.
- My name is Lindsay Albanese,
I'm a celebrity wardrobe sylist,
and I have a fashion YouTube channel
where I share all of my tips, but today
I'm going to help some
people perfect their pose.
It's like a
- [Girl] It looks good.
- [Lindsay] School picture.
Yeah.
- The key when doing a
seated shot is in the legs
and in the arms.
You did one thing really
right, you crossed the legs.
- I always cross my legs.
- Yeah because you know, we
wanna minimize our thighs.
When we sit like this it's like mmmeerrk.
So you just kinda rest your arm,
your forearm on your leg,
and then you're just gonna
kinda lean out a little bit.
The natural you that
everyone wants to see.
- So I was tasked with doing a head-shot.
I'm always caught between like,
do I go full-on serious,
do I go like full-on smile,
and then it ends up
looking like there's like a
bad diaper underneath my nose.
- So the key is to kind of look away,
and then look at the camera,
and then take a deep breath,
and smile as you exhale.
For a candid shot, oh, it's very candid.
Everyone loves a photo that looks candid
and like it was captured in the moment.
Let's just do, you
know, anything you would
naturally do in life.
Like how would you hang
out with your friends?
- I'd probably hang out
like this.
- [Lindsay] Yeah, like that.
Your knees are buckled.
- That's what I do all the time.
- For a signature pose, it's all
in the leg language, and the posture.
So what you're always gonna do,
you're gonna bend one knee,
pop the hip out a little bit, and own it.
- Feels nicer.
I feel sexier already.
- The key to getting this
right is when everyone
huddles together, kind of like look around
to see what people are doing,
and then do the opposite.
And get comfortable and cozy.
One, two, three.
(camera snapping)
- I think we all learned how
to be a little bit sexier today.